we begin with breaking news from Paris
where president macron's government has
narrowly survived two votes of no
confidence in Parliament days after he
pushed through a controversial pension
reform opposition politicians were angry
Macomb bypassed Parliament to raise
their retirement age from 62 to 64. now
for the Motions to have passed parties
from across a deeply divided National
Assembly would have had to unite which
they haven't done let's go live to Paris
Natasha Butler is there for us so the
government has survived what does this
mean Natasha now
well clearly it's good news for the
French government surviving these no
confidence votes that were tabled by
some opposition groups in Parliament
angry over the government's pension
reform bill and the fact the government
pushed that Reform Bill through the
parliament by decree therefore bypassing
Parliament lawmakers said that was
unjust unfair undemocratic that is why
they tabled these no confidence votes
but the government has survived and what
happens now is that it can continue its
work with this pension reform bill it
will now go to the Constitutional court
and it could be signed off into law in
the coming days and weeks but the
political crisis is obviously far from
over because the government survived
these votes only by a very very narrow
margin and what it means is in the
coming months the government's really
going to have to try and find ways to
work with Parliament it doesn't have a
majority in the parliament in to work
with MPS from opposition groups about
what we've seen is opposition groups
accusing the government of being
politically weak are political failure
so it's going to be very rocky road
ahead for macmost government so the
political crisis not over Natasha and
it's likely that the protests and
Strikes are also not over
yes they're certainly not over by any
means because demonstrators say they
want to continue with their protest
because their strategy is that even
though this bill has been pushed through
Parliament and it's going to be on its
way to become a law soon they believe
that by upping the pressure in the
streets
um increasing the pressure on the
government they can try and persuade the
government to scrap this uh pension
reform bill that they say is unfair they
say it's going to be particularly
difficult and have an impact on poorer
workers on women they don't want to work
uh more years they don't want to be
forced to contribute longer to the
pension system the government said all
along though that that is necessary in
order to make advances complex pension
system more sustainable for future
Generations but what we're going to see
next Thursday is a nationwide strike and
protest that's been called for by trade
unions and we're continuing to see
protests we've seen them nearly every
day in the past few days there have been
pockets of violence some unrest some
peaceful process a lot of anger a lot of
frustration among some people who feel
that the French government is out of
touch with the concerns of Ordinary
People is ignoring their concerns and
there's very much a sort of feeling in
the air that there was a few years ago
with a yellow vest movement that sense
of social unrest and social unease and
frustration with the government unless
thank you very much Natasha Natasha back
alive there in Paris let's now discuss
this further with French historian
Francois Jer who's also the founding
president of the French strategic
analysis Institute his life from Paris
fonsi very good to have you with us so
the government has survived the no
confidence motions what is your reaction
first were you expecting this outcome
you know
it's
to some extent the beginning of
a new form of political crisis
today we have the combination of
Street demonstrations
more and more frequent
of strikes which hurts more and more the
economy of the country and at the same
time we see that the government cannot
rely upon a strong political majority
therefore a deep
serious crisis is already opened and we
will see some new elements of this
crisis in the coming hours in the coming
days because
for instance from my own residence in
Paris I can hear demonstrations very
near I can hear police forces alarms and
we are in front of a very very dangerous
social and political crisis
okay so we understand just to clarify
for our viewers who are just joining us
there were two no confidence motions
against the government one motion has
failed so far the other one has not
passed yet how much does this weaken
president
well uh we we we think that the second
notion uh will have a very a small
number of votes uh because it is
supported only by uh right and far right
groups
it's not the the the real important
issue the important issue is that uh
this is born government is no longer
credible right there is a crisis of
legitimacy and president
will have to address this situation how
will he address it in your opinion
Elizabeth born for our viewers of course
is a French prime minister how do you
expect the president to address this
crisis are we going to see the
government resign despite passing uh
despite surviving the no confidence vote
well it's almost obvious that Marco will
have to change prime minister
and it will put the burden of the
political failure upon uh Mrs bomb it's
a very classical move okay is it enough
uh I don't think so uh the president now
is directly in front of the people in
front of a crisis can the pressure I
mean you've mentioned that there were
protests already just outside your
window do you think and the pressure
from the streets and Strikes and
demonstrations that the French have
promised to continue can that force my
car into reconsidering his stance over
this reform
well my sense is that he will have to
um
ask a new government
to reconsider
the political framework
as a whole that means for instance have
referendum vote on the issue of
um with diamonds
and he will have to uh to some extent
transfer part of his power to the
Parliament and to reconsider
the political balance okay uh in France
today okay thank you so much we'll leave
it there thank you so much for talking
to us Housewives our French historian
joining us there Live from Paris we
appreciate it